here's a set of numbers for you 19 20 21
and so on up to 361.
how many numbers exist in this set
including both 19 and 361. how do we
solve this let's see let us start with a
simple example how many numbers are
there between 8 and 12. if we write the
numbers we can see that there are 5
terms and how did we arrive at 5 there's
a formula for this last term minus the
first term plus 1. so here it'll be 12
minus 8 plus 1 which gives us 5. just
remember that these are continuous
integers and there's no gap in between
them so now can you tell me the total
numbers between 19 and 361
yes 361 minus 19 plus 1 which gives us
343 so there are 343 terms in between
these two numbers including the first
and the last numbers now look at this
series of numbers 2 4 6 8 which goes on
after 212
how many terms are present in this set i
will tell you how to solve this quickly
in the next video